anyway you uh you go to a lot of
basketball games yeah I feel like you're
at front row of many I am you're a very
passionate uh about the NBA and the
sport would you say I want to say that I
just
I'm in a blessed ass position in my life
through I get courtside tickets for free
so for free for free how's that work
um my agent a manager and then sometimes
I know the players so Courtside for free
every time you've never paid not a
dollar wow right hand of God I've been
over a hundred in my first NBA game I
was Courtside wow well that's nice God
is great
what have you ever had like a situation
where you're talking [__] or like
somebody was like like you know you're
at Courtside you hear everything yeah so
you heard something maybe you shouldn't
heard no I don't talk now I don't talk
[__] at all because I like to I'm just
there to enjoy the game and I ain't
trying to fight no seven footer plus
you're I got hands are you a Wizards fan
yeah I'm a Wizards fan I mean that's
rough what are you gonna say we got
Bradley Beal like who cares right now
yeah you know for now when you stay
there do you want Bradley Bill to stay
there's no way you want him to stay as
uh Bradley Bill fan or a wizard fan a
wizard fan yeah I want Brad Bill to stay
why because he's like so you can
continue to fight for the night seed
you think we should just tank yes or
Victor win benign I think you guys trade
Bradley Bill kristaps porzingis kuzma
get a bunch of [__] picks well we
gotta we got another restaurant what if
we just get another star then we we
doing something no one's going to DC I
know it's not gonna happen the closest
thing to another star you all got is
that tall awkward white man Chris stops
porzingis oh yeah
it's called the it you're getting a
distressed asset that's the best that's
the best case scenario for the Wizards
get a distressed asset like Chris stops
and he actually comes through and plays
all right which is he doing we just
traded a hoochie um hoochie Rama
what rui hachimura it's not huchirama
nah that sounds like a great porno
speaking of BBC's hoochie Rama baby
hoochie in big uh like 70s letters I'd
watch a movie called hoochie Rama
hoochie Rama baby that sounds like a
great like sitcom too hoochie Rama I
think he's gonna be good for the Lakers
though
yeah he's uh I don't know man was he
good for y'all no he was straight he got
the job done he got the job done
shout out to him yeah you know he's got
his own pair of Jordans
he's got a like a rui hachimura version
of a Jordan six for real I think it's a
six yeah
hey shout out to hey hey young black man
getting money man can't be mad at that